[Music]
this is the story of a world that became
addicted to low interest rates it's a
tale of what can happen when the era of
cheap money comes to an end investors
have just been spoiled for like two
decades by super low interest rates and
it's over the game is up inflation is
here for the first time and most
investors living memories and this
changes everything 30 years of falling
bond yields perhaps coming to an end
suddenly we're at an inflection point
we're seeing some cracks in the
financial system what a decade of easy
monetary policy did was encourage people
to take greater risks T rates rise as
quickly as they have often there are
things that break
at no time have we seen such a
complicated constellation of risks
the only when the Todd goes out that you
see who's been swimming naked
so let's rewind to 2008.
[Music]
Global financial crisis
that was due to leverage too much
borrowing particularly in the U.S
mortgage Market result of that was the
need for incredible liquidity injections
into the financial system in the
immediate aftermath of the global
financial crisis central banks really
had to sit on their hands economies
globally were so lackluster and the
recovery was so slow and central banks
weren't grappling with high inflation
they were grappling with what to do with
incredibly low inflation in central
banks around the world respond to the
recession that follows by slashing
interest rates by buying up vast
quantities of government debt under
their quantitative easing programs this
was a new thing really we saw central
banks buying back
huge amounts of Government Bond markets
trillions and trillions of dollars worth
of government ious ended up being owned
by central banks instead of by
traditional investors and they did set
for the Paradigm if you will of
inexpensive money and a feeling that
there was a fed put below the markets
Federal Reserve and central banks
globally were able to achieve this
because there was no inflation financial
markets in particular get conditioned to
this world where every time something
goes wrong a central bank comes riding
to the rescue ever since that point
we've had loose monetary policy with
interest rates heading all the way down
to zero if you went back to a couple of
years ago most of the Government Bond
markets of the world had negative
yielding government bonds which is just
extraordinary now that existed up until
the pandemic hit and then you had
central banks and governments step in
pretty aggressively to support the
economy
while we put the economy into a deep
freeze the global financial crisis
followed by a Eurozone crisis followed
by covid three big things coming in
Rapid succession in a way we've almost
forgotten what normal looks like there
is everything that leads up to covid and
the invasion of Ukraine and there is
everything after what's changed in one
word inflation there was a belief that
inflation was transitory that this was
caused by supply chain issues during
covid by a tight labor market because of
covid and that would recede and you'd
see inflation coming down a realization
by central banks that this was not the
case inflation was stickier earlier this
year led to this very steep rise in
interest rates the Federal Reserve
officially changed its monetary policy
framework to tolerate higher periods of
inflation what the FED did not Envision
that this framework would become
operational just as inflation was
starting to become a much more
persistent issue
post covered everybody wanted to get out
there again and start flying start
eating out in restaurants at the same
time that we had people who had left the
labor force and a lot of Supply
bottlenecks the perfect breeding ground
for some inflation sustained by the war
in Ukraine so suddenly you had Energy
prices going through the roof
the world has changed the world is
different inflation is here for the
first time and most investors living
memories We've Ended up in a world where
inflation's at 10 percent now what we
have is central banks around the world
scrabbling to stop inflation running
away in every major economy except for
in China and in Japan we had central
banks that are aggressively tightening
rates and also with drying liquidity
from the markets the FED is shrinking
its balance sheet the bank of England
has started quantitative tightening the
ECB is starting to talk about
quantitative tightening financial
markets definitely got used to this
notion that interest rates would be low
for for quite a long time people really
did not grapple with the fact that
interest rates were going to have to be
significantly higher what we hear from
officials is that it's not going back to
the way it was anytime soon you have
inflation for the first time in 40 years
limiting their ability to use a monetary
policy and inject liquidity in the same
way so as a result we're seeing a
drainage of liquidity globally really
higher rates and a new paradigm you can
no longer buy up government debt every
time there's a wobble in the markets
because you need to concentrate on your
main mission which is fighting inflation
there's so much uncertainty that
investors are pulling their money out of
the markets into cash as well so that's
further with frying liquidity the first
really big rake that has been stepped on
here is in the UK pension sector
the bank of England are taking further
steps to control inflation access let's
rewind to September the 23rd we have the
guilt Market which is expecting this new
government to come out with a package of
energy subsidies what they didn't expect
is that the government would pile a load
of unfunded tax cuts on top of this
borrowing even more money than the
market realize it was going to be the
supply of guilts the supply of new debt
that the UK government has to raise has
suddenly gone up the UK Government Bond
Market generally on the boring side it's
kind of a rinky dink little market
compared to the U.S treasury's market it
got fried the market freaked out because
essentially the government was saying we
need to borrow much more money at a time
where it's going to get even more
expensive to borrow money this drove a
sharp sell-off in the UK Government Bond
Market the speed and scale of the move
in the guilts market was unprecedented
and this is what caused a shock the
supply of something goes up investors
respond by selling it you see UK
borrowing costs leap higher on the day
of the budget it was going to result in
the biggest amount of guilt issuance
that we've ever seen the more bonds that
are issued the the more that the market
has to buy at the lower price the
government will have to sell those at
pound crashes to its all-time low
against the dollar usually higher
interest rates would be good for your
currency but we have this this sense
that the International Investment
Community has lost confidence in UK
economic policy making and that caused a
whole bunch of foreselling in the ldi
market liability driven investing or ldi
has been at the center of this this is a
strategy used by certain pension schemes
to protect them against big swings and
interest rates the reason that they need
to do that is because moves in long-term
interest rates mean that their
liabilities the money that they have to
pay out to pensioners for decades in the
future swings up and down wildly now one
way that they can protect themselves
against that is by owning lots of guilts
guilt long-term government bonds that
will also see Wild swings in their
prices as long-term interest rates move
that works if you were able to fill your
pension portfolio with 100 guilt in
practice it doesn't work that way there
are shortfalls in the funding of these
schemes so they need to buy riskier
assets as well the returns that you can
get out of bonds have been falling for
years so they think well we need to
enhance returns they need to hedge
themselves against the risk that Bond
deals could fall further and that's
where derivatives come in that
effectively synthetically create the
same effect of holding long-term guilt
but using leverage using borrowed money
the problem is that if bond yields rise
Pension funds have to pay out that money
that can mean that they have to sell
assets really quickly as guilt yields
climb rapidly in the wake of the budget
that meant that those swap positions
moved against the pension fund the type
of moves that are supposed to be only
seen once in a generation in the guilt
Market we had that happening three days
in a row
so when the guilt price fell the yields
Rose and this meant that Pension funds
faced collateral calls they had to raise
new cash and they had to raise it fast
selling of UK government bonds meant
more selling of government bonds and it
it spiraled incredibly quickly and it
very quickly became a threat to
financial stability in the UK this is a
slow-moving industry these guys are not
used to responding to market conditions
on a day-by-day basis ldi was a strategy
that was sold to companies as something
that you can lock away in the draw and
not think about it wasn't supposed to be
something where pensions trustees and
where companies had to think fast about
which assets they can liquidate in order
to meet margin calls on their collateral
positions if the bank of England hadn't
stepped in there would have been this
Doom Loop of asset sales where it
becomes a sort of self-fulfilling
prophecy and you sell prices into a
falling market and prices keep on
falling and then you risk contagion
across other parts of the market
the bank of England announces that it's
prepared to buy up to 65 billion pounds
worth of guilts of long-term guilts over
the next 13 days which effectively looks
like a return to the days of
quantitative easing precisely at the
time when they're trying to back away
from policies like that the bank of
England had to step in something had to
give ordinary people who pay mortgages
could see that the rates on those
mortgages were shooting through the roof
mortgage lenders were pulling out of the
market it could have developed into a
financial crisis the ldi dynamic you
know exposed the stresses that can
happen in the system when you have a
very sharp rise in interest rates lose
fiscal policy combined with inflationary
backdrop are very dangerous and I think
the financial markets really forced a
coherence in fiscal policy
the bank of England's response to that
was a tactical response inject liquidity
for a moment in time to reverse the
quantitative tightening policy they had
if the bank the Bay of England hadn't
stepped in as the market maker of Last
Resort I think we would have had a
Lehman type event where you had a bunch
of UK pensions go bust Pension funds
knew that the bank of England wasn't
going to let them go bankrupt there was
some reticence to unwind their positions
which is why the governor Andrew Bailey
created this deadline and really stuck
to it so that Pension funds would have
to unwind it rather than just handing it
over to the the bank of England and
allowing the bank of England to take the
losses it was very very tightly targeted
it wasn't a monetary policy move
they were at pains to to point out that
you know this isn't more easing this is
just us making sure that the the system
can hold central banks like the bank of
England wear two different hats one of
them is to set monetary policy and
control inflation and the other one is
to protect Financial stability now for
most of the last decade those two things
have worked pretty well hand in hand
when you had no inflation and low
interest rates it was easy to ride to
the rescue on financial stability
grounds without compromising your
monetary policy with high inflation you
can't do that anymore your financial
stability function no longer pushes in
the same direction as monetary policy
the question is very much whether this
is a very British problem or whether the
UK is a taste of of things to come
the crisis that we've seen in the UK
pension fund Market could be a Harbinger
what's to come elsewhere when you see
rates rise as quickly as they have often
there are things that break they're
going to be a bunch of market
dislocations and it's going to be
central banks that are going to have to
step in to paper them over even as
they're trying really hard to fight
inflation one of the most
famous and off repeated phrases that you
ever hear in financial markets is the
famous quote from Warren Buffett it's
only when the tide goes out that you see
who's been swimming naked it's a great
metaphor for where we are now because as
a liquidity is withdrawn we can see
where all the vulnerabilities are
because they're going to blow up which
investment strategies Which business
models no longer work in a world of
rising interest rates once all of that
lovely liquidity is gone then you find
out what's really at risk in a bull
market almost everything goes up and you
can't see the problems in the portfolio
it's only when the tide goes out or the
markets turn that you see where the
issues are or who's got their trunks
down if you're looking for who's been
swimming naked there's a lot of skinny
dippers out there the places to look are
wherever there's leverage in the system
wherever there's borrowed money when
markets move a long way quickly
people lose money on their leverage
positions and they're forced to sell
Assets in a disorderly way which
exacerbates the moves and creates even
wider problems after the financial
crisis Global Regulators did a lot of
work to make the bank safer as a lot of
the risks got pushed away from the
banking sector into what we call the
shadow banking sector non-bank players
such as hedge funds private Equity
Pension funds and asset managers the
unregulated parts of the financial
sector before the financial crisis
Regulators knew that most of the
leverage was in the banks the problem is
now we don't really know exactly where
the Leverage is
if this can happen to the guilt Market
it could happen to the Japanese
government bond market it could happen
to the U.S treasury's market we have to
be ready for the possibility that bonds
just don't work like they used to
anymore the market dislocations and
price moves that we see in global
markets over the next year will be as
Swift and severe as what we saw in the
UK with the ldi blow up markets broadly
globally are very stressed already
partly it's driven by a disagreement
between governments that want to boost
the economy and central banks like the
bank of England who want to slow the
economy and that store is going to
replay in other parts of the world
including probably this winter in Europe
the European Central Bank has to set
policy for lots of countries that means
one of the things that they're really
worried about is the gaps opening up in
bond markets between what it costs
different countries to borrow and this
is particularly for countries with
weaker economies like Italy or Greece so
far they've been able to get away with
the threat of buying more Italian bonds
to stop this happening but again they
face a similar Dilemma to the bank of
England how do you convince people that
you're still committed to fighting
inflation and at the same time commit to
buy billions of Euros of Assets in order
to stop these cracks opening up in the
financial system
the bank of England certainly sets a
precedent for the FED here
you can imagine a situation where the
FED is forced to intervene to protect
Market functioning while at the same
time they're moving in the opposite
direction in order to reach their
monetary policy objectives it's a very
difficult tight rope to walk when your
financial stability and your monetary
policy functions are pulling in
different directions one of the big
worries in the US is the smooth
functioning of the market for U.S
treasuries which is the world's largest
bond market it's a fundamental part of
the world's Financial Plumbing
everything depends on the fate of the
U.S treasuries market but there are some
real cracks there lots of participants
in that market have been complaining
that liquidity is getting worse but it's
harder to trade bonds without moving the
price but sometimes it's simply
impossible that's a worrying sign when
you're talking about a market that's so
fundamental to the Global Financial
system the US bond market is the
interest rate that sets the global
interest rate everything that happens to
U.S treasuries has implications for
Equity markets property markets your
mortgage rate everything is based based
on U.S treasury bond markets as the
Federal Reserve moves to Titan monetary
policy by raising interest rates and
also by winding down its portfolio of
treasuries people are worried that those
problems may get worse and that you may
end up in a place where the treasury
market simply isn't functioning the
Jersey Market is hands down the world's
most important bond market so
dysfunction in that market is just not
going to be tolerated from the Federal
Reserve that being said there have been
cracks in March 2020 there was this big
broad dash for cash as investors
panicked in the face of the pandemic the
nightmare scenario honestly is that we
get anything like the sort of volatility
that we've seen in guilts happen in U.S
treasuries something similar in the
treasury market is probably a disaster
for the global economy
Bank of America has done a lot of
research into these fragilities that
that it can see occurring in the U.S
treasury's market if the treasury's
market fails to trade for a period of
time various credit channels including
corporate household and government
borrowing and securities and Loans would
cease this could lead to events such as
U.S government debt default not good
inability to convert treasuries to cash
or meet corporate household or
government obligations globally the
inability to produce benchmarks that
form the backbone of the derivatives
Market
the inability to issue trade or hedge
debt of corporates municipalities and
insurance companies Banks I could go on
potentially one of the biggest risks to
financial stability that there has been
anywhere since the housing bubble of
2006 to 2007. we're facing into a
recession across developed markets a
Slowdown in China unbelievable
geopolitical risk a war in Europe I
think the flight to safety might be a
trend that we'll see over the next year
that should support the U.S treasury
market The Logical conclusion is that
there's simply no way that U.S
authorities would stand back and and let
that happen
but yields can rise because prices are
falling in bond markets much more
quickly than we have become used to so
if you have modeling for any kind of
hedging contract anything that's
predicated on rates moving slowly I
would suggest you check the fine print
on that pretty quickly
we've gone from a world where central
banks were the number one buyer of
Government Bond issuance to them being
the biggest seller of government bonds
for me and other Bond investors we don't
quite know how well the global markets
will be able to digest this additional
Supply at the same time that government
borrowing is already quite High
no fed official has officially said uh
you know we need a recession in order to
tame inflation but all signs kind of
point to to that having to be the case
the economy and the country have been
through a lot over the past two and a
half years and have proved resilient
chair J Powell acknowledged the fact
that a recession is a real possibility
and he said something that I think
really shocked investors everyone wants
there to be a painless way to bring
inflation down and there just isn't and
we constantly hear them reference this
1970s period when inflation got out of
control because policy makers
prematurely eased policy and that's just
not a mistake that they're willing to
make this time around Jerome Powell has
been very clear that he's willing to
accept a weaker stock market in pursuit
of lower inflation but if the credit
Market seized up and seized a function I
think the the Federal Reserve just like
the bank of England would be very quick
to intervene and manage that issue big
concern is is how severe of a crisis we
could have going forward and we often
find out when it's too late
the Japanese government bond market is
an outlier inflation is incredibly low
in Japan interest rates are held at more
or less zero and bond yields are held
incredibly low the bank of Japan will
probably have to unravel this policy if
inflation does start to get sticky the
big question that investors are asking
is can Japan do this can it pull this
off without lighting a fuse under the
massive Japanese Government Bond Market
lots of people have spent years looking
for some sort of disaster in the
Japanese government bond market and
they've been disappointed but what is to
say that that market can't do this and
what is to say what the reaction of
Japanese asset managers would be to that
nobody knows the answers to these
questions
one flash point is what's going on with
emerging and developing economies these
are highly indebted countries intimately
affected by Rising borrowing costs
globally by a strong dollar they also do
not have the kind of fiscal robustness
that would allow them to to perhaps
weather through various crises there's
this amazing stat from the IMF 60 of
low-income countries are either near or
at debt distress already we could
perhaps see a wave of defaults going
forward ultra low rates certainly fueled
speculative excess so we saw that in
unprofitable growth companies we saw
that in private Venture Capital back
companies we've seen it in the crypto
world where there's a lot of opacity one
area that we might see potential mines
next year is U.S market for unlisted
tech companies we've seen a big sell-off
enlisted tech companies this year we're
expecting trouble to fall over into the
private markets at some point next year
companies raise money at Sky High
evaluations during the good times and as
interest rates rise they may be forced
to do what's called which is when they
raise money at a big discounted
valuation
UK specifically I think the mortgage
Market is a bit of a risk as well
aggressively in most mortgages are
pretty short term in the UK relative to
the US you could end up having these
fixed term mortgages turn variable with
much higher rates that could blow back
on the bank your mortgage rates are set
related to The Guild Market yields so we
saw UK mortgage rates start to hit six
six and a half I even saw seven percent
mortgage rates
when central banks are pouring money
into the financial markets and they're
Rising it's an incredibly easy
environment in which to invest a rising
tide carries all those low interest
rates and Ultra accommodative monetary
policy has definitely allowed for more
risk-taking than I think would have been
possible when you can't earn a decent
yield a decent interest rate from buying
the safest assets it pushes you into
more dangerous areas encourages you to
take on Leverage to use borrowed money
to juice up your returns we've had a
generation of investors more than a
decade that have gotten used to these
Tailwinds from from low range low
interest rates and and the ability to to
fuel the speculative success
investors should absolutely be braced
for more surprises
there are pockets of hidden leverage in
this economy and financial system that
policy makers have not yet identified
the big concern is how quickly those get
exposed nobody thought that inflation
could jump to 10 percent what if we've
got double-digit inflation in in major
economies and actually we're going to 15
the situation is going to get much
dicier we heard this from the IMF the
worst is yet to come for the global
economy and the Global Financial system
that's pretty strong language are there
any reasons to be cheerful
uh we saw with the UK pensions crisis
that the central banks still are able to
step in and stop the worst problems
without compromising their their
commitment to fighting inflation Bank of
England are taking further steps maybe
the mess that happened in the UK around
the time of the mini budget is enough of
a wake-up call to the rest of the system
if it's not then we're going to get
accidents like this happening over and
over again for the next few years for
inflation rates to stay this high you're
going to need the oil price to keep
going up and up and up if we ended up
with some sort of Peace in Ukraine and
stability then we forget about all the
the extra billions and trillions that
governments and consumers going to have
to be spending on energy bills there has
been a bit of a callback in U.S
inflation in the data for October and
the FED is indicating that maybe it
won't have to raise interest rates quite
as quickly as it had previously told the
market it would so that takes the
pressure off a bit but it's still well
above Target and the pressure is still
very much on China has been a nicero
covid policy for a very long time if
China opens up in 2023 then that could
produce a significant boost to economic
activity around the world
a lot of the pain has been felt in 2022
we've seen rates rise very sharply we've
seen evaluations contract very sharply
markets are all down and there's been a
process of understanding that we're in a
different type of Paradigm higher rates
higher inflation for longer it's hard to
imagine that we can tighten monetary
policies so aggressively have a downturn
in the economy and not see a bunch of
defaults this crisis has
perhaps less potential to spiral through
the financial system we've got the
plumbing set up much better than we did
in 2008 for central banks to go ahead
and step in but at the same time until
inflation can be brought back down and
in until central banks are in a position
where they can reassure the markets
rather than scaring them this is going
to continue
this is the point where policy makers
Reg
ulate this seriously we cannot take the
risk that people's savings are at risk
on Julie that people's pensions are at
risk that house prices could come under
pressure or more importantly the
people's mortgage rates could absolutely
shoot through the roof we could see
trade unions On The Rise Again having
been extinct effectively since the 1980s
and 1970s and we could see wages start
to increase the system was absolutely
addicted to cheap money one investor was
putting it to me the other day it's
absolutely naive to think that we can
get out of this low interest rate
environment
without some sort of blow up
[Music]
[Music]